citadel one of the biggest hedge funds
in the world is getting into crypto ken
uh griffin said the other day the head
of citadel that they are going to start
making markets in crypto he's been a
long uh skeptic of bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies and now it looks like
he is capitulating and saying we're
going to start making markets our
clients are demanding this we need to be
involved in this market so
i think we had a a tweet or an article
from bloomberg where he references
exactly his position on the previous
stuff but ken griffin's been in the news
a lot recently he has said that uh he
tried by the constitution dow i know he
gave a bunch of money to a republican
candidate for governor or or another
political position yeah here we go he
bought a rare copy of the u.s
constitution at auction for 43 points
beating out a doubt yeah beating out the
constitution dao just total troll job
saying hey screw you crypto bros uh then
he described the rush to embrace
cryptocurrencies as a jihadist call
against the us dollar interesting choice
of words there obviously uh griffin also
gave 20 million dollars to a republican
candidate for governor so he has been in
the news a lot recently and then i know
that he also said that the he believes
american sanctions
uh they they feel good in the short term
he said but can be hurt in the long run
and that the u.s is weaponizing the
dollar dollars can be seized telling the
rest of the world to embrace other
currencies inadvertently diminishing the
value of the dollar as of currency and
if that isn't what is happening right
now i don't know what it is right that's
literally a perfect example but this is
what he told uh
bloomberg i believe uh earlier uh in the
year he said the other partner that you
sold at us or they asked him sorry the
other partner that you sold the stake to
was a cryptocurrency related investor
you haven't been trading or making
markets in crypto what about the future
crypto has been one of the great stories
in finance over the course of the last
15 years and i'll be clear i've been in
the naysayer camp over that period of
time but the crypto market today has a
market cap of almost 2 trillion dollars
in round numbers which tells you that i
haven't been on the right of this call i
still have my skepticism but there are
hundreds of millions of people in this
world today who disagree with that to
the extent that we're all trying to help
institutions and investors solve their
portfolio allocation problems we have to
give serious consideration to being a
market maker in crypto it's fair to
assume that over the next months over
the months to come you will see us
engage in making markets
cryptocurrencies that obviously has
happened now that that news has come out
that article was published previously
and i think that those uh comments
everyone obviously saw this coming
because he literally said it but
ultimately he's right that one he has
been wrong
bitcoin has gone from essentially uh
pennies on the dollar or cents to now
it's a 45 000
uh us dollar price per bitcoin it's a
multi-trillion dollar asset eventually
we believe it will be in the total
market is two trillion dollars so uh he
he has been wrong on that side he could
made a bunch of money his firm could
have made a bunch of money by acquiring
bitcoin or other digital assets
investing in infrastructure doing all
these different things he's been wrong
he he admitted it and he's been wrong
he's obviously a very smart person uh
he's gotten a lot of things right in his
career but he's been wrong about this
now what he is saying
is our clients they want portfolio
allocation to this asset and we want to
help solve those problems for them so
we're going to start making markets he
didn't say hey we're going to go buy a
bunch of bitcoin we're going to go buy a
bunch of ether other assets or nfts or
any of this stuff he's not necessarily
changing his mind what he's saying is
i'm changing my mind on the ability uh
that our firm is going to offer this is
obviously a big asset class our clients
want exposure to it whether they whether
we think it's valuable or not we are
going to start making markets in this
asset because of that i think that's an
important thing to note there he's not
necessarily going all in but he is
saying we're seeing uh clear
institutional demand for this and we
need to start making markets in this
what do you think about it john
yeah i
give him a lot of credit for kind of
stating that he was wrong and obviously
the price appreciation of it
almost an asset class that was not
existent basically a decade ago um that
he's like look we could have made some
money here right and he's talking about
being a market maker basically saying
look we can play the market they're not
gonna sounds like just go out and buy a
bunch of bitcoin and hold it forever uh
similar like to the micro strategy
to microstrategy's strategy but look
he's trying to be a market maker he
understands that this is obviously an
asset that class that's not going
anywhere you see in the last few years
bloomberg adds a crypto tab to their
website every every um every major news
outlet in the financial markets has been
consistently talking about
cryptocurrencies because not only is it
volatile but because of um all the
technology that goes behind it and the
rapid rapid price it's up almost a
million percent since uh in the last
decade right so the rapid price
appreciation combined with the
technology that's being built um and the
adoption that has happened globally with
this asset class he's like okay i gotta
get involved right whether somehow i
gotta make money i to give my investors
ass access to this asset class and
that's exactly what he's doing here it
makes a lot of sense and yeah he has
been in the news a lot lately um buying
that constitution and dow i believe was
basically just a troll against crypto i
don't really see him wanting wanting
that actual constitution i believe his
son basically told him his doubts going
after the constitution uh we basically
can see their bid because they they it's
such it's public information we can see
their bid um so let's go ahead and beat
that with a 43 million dollar bid i
think the dow was at like close to 40
million dollars so he did just enough to
beat it but didn't want to over splurge
and overpay for the constitution yeah
and one of the funniest things about
this to me is like uh it was only a
matter of time in my mind before he had
to say i was wrong right like whether
you own the asset or not when you're in
a position like him and you own one of
the largest hedge funds in the world you
have to be involved in this market to
his point now it's a multi-trillion
dollar market you can't ignore it when
you have institutional clients when you
have big clients that want to be
involved in this right there's hundreds
of millions of people that are involved
in this asset and want exposure to this
asset both buying and selling right so
now he has to go and make markets and
say hey look we're going to help from a
portfolio allocation standpoint but we
were wrong because we didn't think it
was going to be necessary we didn't
think we'd get to this point where it
was a big enough asset where it forced
itself to be included that's ultimately
what bitcoin did was it forced him it
forced his hand said look we are too big
now where you're in a position where you
own this firm and you cannot ignore us
any longer and that's what's going to
happen to all these people right every
single hedge fund manager every single
bank ceo every every single person in a
high financial position at one of these
institutions is going to get to a point
where they say we cannot ignore this any
longer our clients want exposure to this
and what do they have to do they have to
answer to their clients they have to
answer to their shareholders they have
to answer to the people who make their
job possible and give them profits and
give them the ability to run their
business and again what we're going to
find is they're going to have to
capitulate they're going to have to
start not only making markets some of
them are going to start buying bitcoin
some of them are going to start
including it as allocations within
people's portfolio one two three five
percent digital assets right they're
going to give them exposure to these
things because their clients are going
to demand it they're going to ask for
cookie cutter portfolios instead of 60
40. hey maybe there's a five percent
allocation to digital assets like that's
going to happen in my mind and it's only
a matter of time before it does so ken
griffin is is one of them we've seen
others in the past and we're going to
continue to see people going forward of
people that come out in these high
ranking positions people that are really
really well respected and have built
incredible careers over the last 20 to
50 years and say not only was i wrong
but we're going to do something about it
we're going to start making markets in
this we're going to start allocating
bitcoin or other digital assets to
people's portfolio because eventually
you get to a point where the asset is
too big it's not going away right not
only the companies and the
infrastructure and kind of the
investments that are going into the
space but the asset itself right bitcoin
ethereum all these other ones people are
saying i want exposure to this and if
you're if you're a an institutional shop
that has retail clients or uh qualified
investors or accredited investors or
people of that nature
you're not giving them
access to something they want they're
going to leave and that's what people
ultimately will do they'll vote with
their wallets they'll vote with their
feet and they'll say i need exposure to
this if you're not willing to do it it's
okay if you don't believe in it right
bet with your own dollar short it do
something else but ultimately i want
exposure to it if you're a firm that
can't give it to me i'm going to go
somewhere else so we're going to
continue to see this ken griffin is not
the first he's not going to be the last
there will be other high-ranking hedge
fund managers there will be other bank
ceos that come out and say i was wrong
we're going to start doing this we're
going to start allocating to portfolios
we're gonna make markets we're gonna do
a bunch of different things
again i was wrong i may not believe in
it but here we are we got we we need to
be involved i give him a lot of credit
for saying he was wrong i hope people
kind of accept ken griffin into the
bitcoin and crypto community with open
arms i think the biggest thing is people
basically troll someone they're like oh
you're wrong you were wrong he's like
i'm admitting i was wrong now i want to
learn about this asset and i want to
move forward with that uh but we see
companies like jp morgan with jamie
dimon and saying hey i think bitcoin's
worthless but hey if my clients want
access to it i'll go ahead and give them
access to and i'll help them kind of get
involved in the asset class itself but
yeah look these people answer to their
clients and their clients help them fund
every single idea and fun that they have
and
investments into companies so they have
to answer these these people and these
people are um their clients and their
high wealth clients are not dumb they
don't get that much money by making dumb
market moves and i think having your
clients money in bonds or something else
that is almost negative returning what
we've seen over the last year is they're
gonna be pissed and they're gonna say
hey look not only are you not making me
money and someone says you're losing me
money by being in this asset i need to
be involved in an asset that's not only
gonna appreciate in value over the next
day but over the next decade and i think
that's what more and more people are
saying hey they're ringing the bell and
saying i want to be involved in crypto i
don't care what bank you are you could
be jp morgan you'd be goldman sachs you
could be ubs you could be more
constantly it could be any of these
major banks that have a have a
significant wealth management arm and if
you go to a 25 year old today who is
ingrained in this stuff and say hey look
uh you have a couple million bucks you
started a company you do something
whatever whatever it ends up being right
but a client that they would have at a
young age someone that has some kind of
serious amount of money whether they
inherited it whether they started a
company whether they earned it whatever
it is if you go to them and you say hey
our recommendation for you is a balanced
60 40 portfolio you're going to go to
stocks and we'll slowly move that around
and as you get older you'll eventually
be 60 bonds and then we'll move down to
40
stocks and we'll keep moving that until
you retire and you'll have cash flow and
we'll invest in dividend stocks and all
these things they're going to tell you
to get the hell lost right they don't
give a [ __ ] about that they don't want
nothing to do with that it's completely
different times have changed these kids
want exposure to [ __ ] shoes
as investments you know what i mean they
want exposure to trading cards they
don't want anything to do with negative
returning bonds they want nothing to do
with that so shoes and trading cards are
separate but ultimately when it comes to
banks they're going to have to offer
exposure to digital assets it's an asset
class that isn't going away one but two
when clients demand it you have to do it
so i i laugh when i see some of these
people still talking about 60 portfolios
they've been dead they're dead they're
not coming back they're done people want
exposure to different things we're
seeing the financialization of
everything right back to the shoe
component there's literally uh
fractionalization companies that are
buying these artifacts and you're going
to sell them and people have that as
part of their portfolio and it's not
just like on the side hey i'm gambling a
little bit like they literally count
that as part of their portfolio nfts are
the same thing there's a million
different examples you can give whether
it's trading cards or art or something
else right these companies are all
spawning up and they're giving
fractionalization and these are all part
of people's portfolio because they're
understanding hey look i'm not gonna get
rich buying bonds and sitting here on a
coupon of three four five percent a year
and trying to make money that way i'm
not going to get rich buying these
dividend stocks i'm keen to do it right
and there's a playbook obviously if
you're in the market long enough and you
continue to compound capital and you're
able to do it for a long period of time
sure you're going to get wealthy like
that that that is uh that is that can't
be argued at this point but i think
ultimately what young people are saying
is we want exposure to different assets
we can do this in a different way we
have upside or we think the world is
viewed in a different capacity than it
was in the past and ken griffin all
these other ceos they're gonna be in the
same position as everyone else you're
gonna have to offer it because that's
what young people are demanding they're
the ones coming in with the fresh
capital as money moves from older
generations to new generations people
continue to compound capital and get
larger portfolios this is the stuff they
want exposure to it's not the bonds and
i think they're going to understand that
and they're going to realize we need to
start making markets we need to start
offering it to our clients yeah i have a
friend actually who recently went and
reached out to a bank and kind of had
them manage some of his money um and
it's really interesting to see i was
talking about what assets they were
recommending and you know they talked
about how much risk you have he's young
so he has that ability to be a little
bit uh more risk adverse but
he was like dude bonds didn't get
brought up in the conversation gold
didn't get brought up in the
conversation they did bring up a
balanced stock uh portfolio and being
able to wait it and the advantages they
have there
but he's not into crypto so he was like
crypto didn't really get brought up
maybe they mentioned it um but he didn't
he didn't move forward with that but
it's interesting to see that they're not
even like especially the younger clients
these hedge funds are not pitching
uh bonds and they're not pitching gold
as an investment uh because they know
that that is more of a um
it can kind of protect your wealth
rather than actually help grow your
wealth hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time